[Музика]
привіт усім, мене звуть Амна,
ласкаво просимо на урок англійської мови,
сьогодні ми продовжимо
розмову про молодіжну культуру,
хобі, стиль життя молоді, і одне з
хобі — це мода, тому мода — наша
сьогоднішня тема  урок
які у вас асоціації з
модою подивіться
мої асоціації наступний
подіум
перш за все так, тому що мода і
моделі і подіум, тому подіум - це
місце, де моделі демонструють одяг в
моді, що є одним з найвідоміших
модних журналів, костюм костюма
класичний костюм - це те, що
ви обов'язково одягнете на офіційний
захід гламур, який не асоціює
гламур з модним одягом, звісно,
г і одяг загалом є ос
овною частиною ікон мо
и модні тенденції стиль Тиждень моди, до ре
і, коли ми говорили  про подіум
і моделей, це, безумовно, слово,
яке у нас асоціюється з модою
Esquire також журнал про моду так само, як
vlog Idol photography маленька чорна
сукня,
створена Коко Шанель на
початку 20 століття, є одним із знакових
модного одягу і останнім мішкуватим
одягом, який є тенденцією сучасної моди,
і підлітки молоді люди вважають за краще
носити мішкуватий одяг у своєму повсякденному
стилі  Гаразд,
тепер, коли ми переглянули деякі
асоціації з модою, давайте подумаємо
про недоліки та
переваги моди, тож, що добре в
дотриманні модних тенденцій, а що погано
в дотриманні модних тенденцій, що
насправді є перевагою, що є
недоліком, тож давайте подумаємо зараз  ваше
завдання - створити список з п'яти
переваг модних тенденцій і п'яти
недоліків з них, у вас є хвилина
на це
[Музика]
добре, тепер у вас є свої списки, ви
можете порівняти їх з моїми, тому переваги
впевненість - перша перевага
Слідування модним тенденціям полягає в тому, що ви
отримуєте впевненість у собі, тому, коли
ви носите гарний одяг,
ви точно починаєте почувати себе краще
ще одне відчуття ідентичності, щоб ви
могли знову приєднатися до спільноти, третя
перевага - це спільнота однодумців, тому
ви відчуваєте, що ви є частиною групи
з людьми, які вас цікавлять,
наприклад, мода, і
одяг корисний для  майбутня кар'єра по-
різному насправді це або те, що
ви знаєте, що носити в різних
випадках, або ви можете знати багато про
моду, і це насправді допоможе вам
отримати роботу в цій сфері що щодо
недоліків подивіться
пріоритети змінити що це означає
коли ви починаєте постійно слідкувати за модними
тенденціями, ви можете забути,
що вам також потрібно вчитися, тому ви
забуваєте про своє навчання, а це
означає, що ваші пріоритети змінилися,
ви цінуєте моду більше, ніж свій
розвиток з точки зору інтелекту та
шкільних предметів, тому забудьте  про це
дорого наступний недолік
моди, коли ти стежиш за модними тенденціями,
тобі потрібно купувати багато одягу, щоб бути
модним, тому це зазвичай дорого  тому
вам доведеться стати марнотратником,
вам доведеться витрачати багато грошей на
одяг і це не добре,
звичайно, втрачати себе, коли російські для
модних тенденцій
намагаючись не відставати від моди ви можете
втратити себе ви можете забути про те, що
ви особисто  подобається те, що ти хотів
би одягнути, щоб не втратити себе,
коли ти бігаєш за модою і
останній шкідливий дієт, що це
означає, як це стає
недоліком моди, звичайно,
ми знаємо, що гарна сукня  напевно,
потрібне гарне тіло, але це те, що люди думають
так,
молоді дівчата починають сидіти на дієті, і вони їдять все
менше і менше, і це стає шкідливим
для їх здоров’я, тому мода
може бути шкідливою, і це один з
основних недоліків моди та
слідування модним тенденціям, але  звичайно
, не забуваймо, що важливо
зберігати баланс, щоб ви могли слідувати
модним тенденціям, але не забувайте про
вивчення здоров’я та інші важливі
речі,
тепер ми в  щоб прочитати текст про
те, як мода насправді може зашкодити молодим
людям мода боляче, яким чином вона
може зашкодити емоційно і це може зашкодити
фізично, давайте прочитаємо текст і дізнаємося
, що він розповідає нам про моду
мода шкодить носити модний
одяг може бути шкідливим для вас  це може
вас здивувати, але кажуть, що деякий
одяг може викликати проблеми з f1f. Вам
важко повірити в це.
Дослідники виявили, що
дотримання останньої моди також може бути
шкідливим для здоров’я, наприклад, якщо ви зав’язуєте шарф
занадто туго, це підвищує ваш кров’яний
тиск  джинси та штани короткі
спідниці та навіть розумне взуття на плоскій підошві може бути
причиною того, що три експерти кажуть, що речі, які
ми носимо, можуть бути й для: проблеми зі шлунком,
пориви спини та болі в ногах, але
як пояснити, що дуже тісний
одяг може заважати людям рухатися
природним чином, а це
не так  добре для вас, якщо ви носите штани або
спідниці, які занадто обтягують
талію, тоді вашому животу не буде
п’яти, щоб розширитися після  ви їли, і
це може викликати біль у животі. Висипання можуть
бути викликані алергічним
шести-два синтетичним матеріалом, і
не в останню чергу носіння взуття на високих підборах
може призвести до проблем з їжею та спиною, навіть
практичне взуття може викликати біль у спині, якщо
вони не 7u  правильно, тепер ми
прочитали текст про моду та про те, як це
може бути шкідливо для нашого тіла, тому будьте
уважні, у нас є деякі прогалини в
тексті, наше завдання зараз - заповнити
пропуски словами, але у нас
будуть слова  у списку зліва
ви можете побачити перший абзац
тексту, праворуч ви можете побачити
можливі відповіді, тому тепер наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
вибрати правильний варіант для кожного пробілу
давайте подивимося на перше речення
носити модний одяг може бути погано
для вас це може вас здивувати, але
кажуть, що деякий одяг може спричинити
різноманітність.
Колекція проблем. Тож, що
частіше кажуть англійською:
різноманітність проблем, група проблем,
набір проблем чи набір проблем.  f проблеми,
яку ви виберете,
дайте їй щось окрім добре,
це має бути слово різноманітність
різноманітність проблем – це фраза, яку
ми повинні використати тут, давайте перейдемо до номеру
два. Дослідники виявили,
що слідуючи останнім напрямкам моди,
тенденції змінюються
культури можуть бути нездоровими, тому, коли ми
говоримо про зміну моди та
правила, які мода диктує нам, яке
слово ми будемо використовувати, добре,
звичайно, це слово тенденції, тому ми
говоримо, що модні тенденції можуть бути
нездоровими наступним: вузькі джинси та
штани  короткі спідниці та навіть розумні
плоскі туфлі можуть викликати номер три
скарги, хвороби, хвороби,
то що це означає,
то тут у нас є скарги на проблеми,
пов’язані з хворобами
Станні.  ми говоримо про хворобу
або хворобу, але ми говоримо не
тільки про одну, ми говоримо про багато
з них, тому нам потрібно  виберіть слово
хвороби в цьому пропуску, останнє в
цьому абзаці, давайте подивимося на
речення, які кажуть експерти, що речі, які ми носимо,
можуть також розвиватися, щоб рухатися –
проблеми зі шлунком, тому якщо ми скажемо, що ця дія
обережно, прати свою сорочку
натиснути на борт, тому що люблю, коли я CDP
зробив цей рух, перевірте, ростуть,
звичайно добре, це слово привести, вони
також призводять до проблем зі шлунком, добре, давайте зараз
поглянемо на другий абзац
і пробіл номер п'ять, якщо ви були брюками
чи спідницями, які  надто тісні навколо
талії, то у вашому животі немає
п'яти протяжних площ, місця, тож про що
ми говоримо тут, ми говоримо
про простір, а синонімом простору в
даному випадку буде слово кімната
нового мій пане,
тому ми '  Треба сказати, що у вашому шлунку
немає місця для розширення. Наступна одна
висипка номер шість може бути викликана
алергічною відповіддю. Повернутися,
як правильно сказати, добре, ми
скажемо, що це має бути алергія
реакція, тож це фраза для цієї
алергічної реакції, а остання
номер сім, навіть практичне взуття може
викликати біль у спині, якщо вона не підходить за формою до
костюма чи не підходить вам належним чином, тож яку з них
ми маємо вибрати тут, це більше
стосується форми, а не  правильне слово,
яке слід використовувати тут, а як щодо матчу, ми
використовуємо слово match, коли говоримо, що
щось добре для нас, воно виглядає добре на
нас, тому ми не говоримо про те,
добре виглядає взуття чи ні на нас чи ні
ми  кажучи, що вони повинні нам підходити,
тому слово костюм також не зустрічається, і ми
повинні використовувати слово підходять, говорячи про
взуття, яке підходить нам, щоб це означає, що вони
мають правильний розмір, правильну форму,
і вони також підходять для налаштування  NOS, тож
трохи добре, добре, тепер давайте
подивимося на іншу вправу, яку нам потрібно
зробити, нам потрібно розкрити дужки та
поставити дієслова у правильні форми, щоб
перше речення носити модний одяг
могло бути погано для вас, яка форма
слово туди, куди ми повинні його поставити  re so
that will be wearing, ми будемо використовувати
герундій, закінчення дієслова, і
воно перетворилося на іменник або jumper at
were a lady slow what to wear ooh a man
wearing epigenome is know виникло
між бігти зловісним роком you won'  t
see big mata kadala
давайте перейдемо до наступного. Чи вам
це важко повірити, так що нам
потрібно використовувати
після прикметника важко ми будемо
використовувати два плюс дієслово, тому ми скажемо, чи вам
важко повірити в
наступне число  три дуже тісного одягу може
перешкоджати людям рухатися природним шляхом, і
це не добре для вас, добре, ви пам'ятаєте,
як це звучало в тексті, чи, можливо, ви
просто знаєте правило, тому не дозволяйте людям
рухатися природним шляхом, щоб після запобігання
комусь ми використовували ing okay четверте
зараз  якщо ви носите штани або спідниці,
які занадто тісні навколо талії, у вашому
животі не буде місця після
того, як ви поїли, і це може викликати
біль у животі, тому він не має місця,
а після іменника тут після слова
room we w  погане використання інфінітиву, яке означає
розширення, і останнє речення номер п'ять
і не в останню чергу носіння взуття на
високих підборах може призвести до проблем з їжею та спиною,
тому тут ми маємо те саме,
що ми могли бачити в номері один, ми знову
повинні використовувати носити  Форма
слова why, оскільки
в даному випадку це підмет речення,
добре, тому тепер, коли ви побачили
використання герундію та інфінітива в
реченнях з тексту, давайте
подивимося на правила, які ми використовуємо, коли
говоримо про Jaren's  і коли ми фактично
використовуємо герундій ing у своїй мові
сильно, тому Джерод вживається після
прийменників, що таке прийменники короткі
зустрічаються прийменники pre вдалося отримати
нирки село Козлов і абрикос, щоб
додати без і так далі,
тому подивіться на  Наприклад, вони
визнали скоєння злочину, нашим прийменником
тут є слово to, а після нього ми
маємо слово committing, яке означає герундій
наступне, Леслі вибачилася за те, що
забула мій день народження, тому ми в  звичайно
вибачте за те, що робите щось, тому у нас є
прийменник for, а потім ми використовуємо ing тут
це вибачте за те, що забули і
не забувайте про TT в таких випадках,
а третій приклад — це думати про
навчання за кордоном, так що це прийменник
і після прийменника ми  використання
мислення про навчання добре, це
перше правило, а друге, є
багато прикметників + прийменник, який є
прагматичним + виняткові комбінації та
іменник + прийменник у магніті + комбінації простих і
ік, які також
супроводжуються герундіями, виглядають
пісочний, страшно  of flying here у нас є
прикметник + прийменник scared is the
прикметник
then прийменник of and then flying is
the gerund ing the second Нік
хвилюється про здачу іспиту
знову тривожний прикметник про
прийменник узятий це наш герундій номер 3
його інтерес до того, щоб стати сноубордистом
був  добре відомий, тому інтерес є іменником
прийменником у становленні є наш герундій,
а четвертий приклад розповідає нам історію
про seein  ga ведмідь грізлі був дуже
захоплюючим, і тут у нас є іменник, який
є розповіддю про прийменник і сцену,
це наш герундій, добре, тому є
комбінації, за якими слідує герундій,
наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб запам'ятати їх, а тепер давайте
подивимося на речення та наше
Завдання полягає в тому, щоб вибрати правильний пункт у
кожному реченні, тому подивіться на
перший, про який
говорив Саймон,
росте або виростає в Танзанії, у
неї був такий інтерес до життя, тому
тут у нас є слово,
про яке є прийменником і  ми
пам'ятаємо, що після нього має бути
герундій, тож вона говорила про
зростання в Танзанії, а як щодо
другого,
мені потрібно, щоб він допомагав або щоб допомогти мені підняти
цю важку коробку, що я використовую після
дієслова neat is it to плюс інфінітив  to
plus дієслово or is it in ing, так що тут ми
обов'язково використаємо інфінітив, тому to help
є правильним варіантом тут Мені потрібно, щоб він
допоміг мені підняти цю важку
коробку третій, дякую, що прийшли або
прийшли на зустріч на такому  короткий
ні  Зверніть увагу, тут ми маємо слово для прямо
перед дієсловом, тому нам потрібно використати
ing, спасибі за приїзд, номер чотири я
пропоную відвідати або відвідати Японію,
коли вишневі дерева цвітуть, тож який
був би правильний варіант тут,
звичайно,  be the word visiting Я
пропоную відвідати Японію після дієслова
пропонує ми будемо використовувати ing номер п'ять ми
найняли професійних перекладачів для
перекладу або перекладу документів
на арабську та китайську, тож що
ми маємо вибрати тут, звичайно, це
перекладати номер шість після роботи я завжди
йду  біг підтюпцем або я завжди йду на роботу я фанат
фітнесу,
тож бігай підтюпцем чи бігай,
що тут вибрати
, не забувай після слова go, коли
ми говоримо про фізичну активність, нам
потрібно використовувати ing, тому бігай після роботи
Я завжди бігаю підтюпцем, і
, до речі, що таке фанат фітнесу, чи людина,
яка без
розуму від спорту, яка без розуму від
фітнесу, добре, номер сім, тепер його
інтерес до навчання чи вивчення
мов дуже вражає  ve interest — це
іменник in — це прийменник, за яким має
слідувати, і герундій це правильно, тому
його інтерес до вивчення мов
дуже вражаючий,
наступне число вісім Роберта
втомлюється робити або робити ту саму
стару роботу день у день  Я думаю, що вона
збирається кинути, тому для Роберти вона
втомилася виконувати ту саму роботу,
звісно,
у це прийменник, за яким сл
дує герундій номер дев'ять. Ме
ики заохочують людей їсти аб
їсти менше червоного м'яса, тому ми заохочуємо ко
ось  робити щось або робити
щось у нашому попередньому уроці ми
говорили про індивідуальну пораду, і
ось, ми повинні використовувати людей, щоб
їсти, тому ми кажемо, що медичні працівники
заохочують людей їсти менше червоного м’яса,
добре, це майже все з цією
вправою  давайте подивимося на
інший, ми повинні використовувати дієслова в
дужках, щоб заповнити пропуски, тому номер один
ми домовилися зустрітися під вокзалом
о пів дев'ятої, а ми
зустрічалися або будемо використовувати  d зустріч якщо ми
домовимося про щось, що ми будемо використовувати для зустрічі
двох плюс інфінітив номер два я завжди
намагаюся уникати бачити його, коли можу,
яку форму дієслова to see або seen
ми будемо використовувати після дієслова уникнути that's
ing я завжди намагаюся уникати  я бачу його
щоразу, коли можу третій, я хотів
би знову поїхати до Шотландії,
чи це речення звучить добре так, це
нам не потрібен герундій, тож
подорожувати – це правильний
варіант наступний номер для моєї мами вимагала,
щоб менеджер зробив  ми вимагаємо
щось зробити або ми вимагаємо зробити
щось насправді, щоб зробити щось
, тому моя тітка вимагала побачити
менеджера номер п'ять
мій брат відмовився їсти мій шоколадний
мус, можливо, його хом'як з'їв його так
відмовив їсти або відмовився їсти після
дієслова denied  ми будемо використовувати ing мій
брат відмовився їсти мій шоколадний
мус номер сім я намагався
зрозуміти, але я просто не зміг, тому я
намагався зрозуміти або я намагався
зрозуміти після дієслова спробувати
, частіше використовують два pl  us
інфінітив, тож ми скажемо, що я намагався це
зрозуміти, але я просто не зміг,
і в кінці кінців я відмовився від
спроби переконати її, чи ми відмовимося зробити
щось, чи ми відмовимося робити
щось, роблячи щось, що є  чому
нам потрібно використовувати дієслово Try з ing,
тож зрештою я відмовився від спроб
переконати її,
добре зроблено, тож тепер давайте подивимося на
два стовпці.
дієслова
в першому стовпці ми будемо використовувати герундій,
форму ing, наприклад признати робити
щось не можу терпіти робити щось
насолоджуватися робити щось кинути робити
щось ненавиджу почати і розум робити
щось дієслово плюс інфінітивні дієслова
, за якими слідують 2 плюс інфінітив
або дієслово  Основна форма дієслова вирішити
зробити щось
для зробити щось потрібно зробити щось
відмовився зробити щось спробувати зробити
щось і захотіти щось зробити oh
і, звичайно, хотів би зробити щось
добре, тож де ми можемо побачити e  Приклади
цих дієслів, які використовуються носіями мови,
звичайно, пісні, тому перше, що ви
можете почути в пісні Тейлор Свіфт, вам
потрібно заспокоїтися, у нас є дієслово need, за
яким слід два плюс інфінітив
номер два queen I want to break free so
ми маємо дієслово want, за яким
слід два плюс інфінітивне число три
Неллі Фуртадо скажи це правильно, коли
немає часу на жарт, тут у нас є
прийменник, після якого йде
слово жарт і який є герундієм,
тож n-им числом для них  все в камені, що
живе в місті-привиді, і є
рядок, коли це місце гуло, і
повітря було сповнене драматизації. Зверніть увагу,
у першій частині речення, у
нас минуле безперервне гуло, тож
це просто безперервна форма  дієслово,
але у другій частині повітря було
сповнене барабанами, тут це іменник
pooja amman live as continuum ing, тож
тут ми маємо прийменник, а потім
форму герундію ing okay, тож настав
час отримати домашнє завдання.
домашнє завдання полягає в тому, щоб вивчити
список дієслів, за якими слідує герундій, вивчити
список слів, за якими йде інфінітив,
а за останнім ви також можете послухати
одну з пісень, згаданих на
попередньому слайді, тому дуже дякую
за увагу, це все  сьогодні
побачимось наступного разу
[Музика].